what pet animal in your life do you miss
the
most that has been in your
life that you think about I've never had
cats or dogs growing up or anything like
that which you know I oh
God my problem is here we go if I like
something I will go down a rabbit hole
mhm yeah so I know if I got one tattoo I
already know my first five are get be
okay so I can't do it cuz then once I
get those five it's going to be 100 and
I'm already too old to be the tattoo guy
what would be the first tattoo um my
face um would it go on your ass cheeks
or where would you put them if it was my
face if I got your face it would
definitely be on my arm right here if
you had multiple faces would you put
like I think delts right shoulders
different faces and different shoulders
symmetry yeah yeah would you get a
dictator
if you if you had to get a dictator who
would you get we have Kim jnel right H
because I wrote the book on him oh it's
like plugging your book I don't think
plugging it's just like I have a
personal connection to good opener
conversation people would be asking why
him and you'd be like well I wrote a
book about it well i' be like okay okay
here here's what that would be a bad no
that's not what happens okay here's the
thing what happens when you write a book
about North hey nice to meet you what is
it you do I'm an author what kind of
books do you write well my last book was
about North Korea 90% of the time 90
they will then start telling me
everything they know about North Korea
and it's like I don't need this isn't a
quiz and it's a very poorly understood
country I don't expect you to know
anything you're not on the spot and and
half what you're saying is not accurate
either it's fine how often did they
bring up Dennis Rodman uh 100% 100% of
the time oh so you do you know Dennis
Rodman yeah but I don't understand what
I guess people feel the need to like all
right like now we're talking about this
subject I just got to you know drop
whatever I can talk about it's usually a
small amount and there's this thing in
the culture which I hate that everyone
have to have an opinion on everything
and it's like it's okay to be like yeah
I don't know anything about that tell me
more you know there's lots of things I
don't know anything about what's your
opinion
on my bird here Mr parrot it's maau
Scarlet maau what it is a Scarlet Macau
oh you know Birds yeah and that's
actually not life-sized
are you saying he's not real I'm saying
it's not to scale okay but he's real are
we doing that Monty Python
sketch everything is a Monty Python I
don't think Monty Python's funny and at
all like not that explains so much does
it what does it explain what do you
think is
funny you're not answering that question
is pretty funny yeah what what do you
think is funny having a met to shrimp no
you think Bigos is funny oh God no
although this is getting worse and worse
to be fair yep I only tried to watch big
Labowski after it's been part of the
culture for many years right to the
point where every single line has been
quoted incessantly by the most annoying
frat Bros ever yeah so I kind of have
been poisoned to be able to appreciate
it right so maybe if I'd seen it when it
came out before it became a thing I
would have enjoyed it I couldn't get
through it like I couldn't get through
20 minutes is that how you feel about a
Schindler's
List well it's so much easier for me to
stare at you when you have sunglasses on
I didn't think you'd be the one making
Holocaust jokes today and yet here we
are and cut scene I actually have like
no trouble making eye contact with you
when you're wearing Shades yes cuz
you're a robot two two copies of myself
yeah oh you seeing yourself in them mhm
okay cool yeah I'm having a conversation
with myself it's not your fault
Lex they made you like this you were
just a good little robot in in St
Petersburg I could see Mr parrot a
little bit
too